[Musique]
avec l'arrivée du coronavirus la planète
entière si mise au ralenti les rues se
sont vidées
mais pendant que l'humain se confinait
d'autres espèces animales ont eu le
champ libre pour se réapproprier le
territoire
ces derniers mois des photos inusité
d'animaux en ville ont fait le tour du
web
le confinement à donner aux chercheurs
en biologie en mycologie une occasion
inattendue et unique d'étudier l'effet
de l'activité humaine sur la faune des
chercheurs de l'université st andrews au
royaume uni ont donné un nom à cette
pause forcée de l'activité humaine
l'autre pause grâce à l'entrepôt zh
on a pu découvrir que d'humains était le
seul facteur qui empêchait des animaux
d'occuper certains territoires
c'est parce que les animaux savent
instinctivement qu'elles ont de leur
habitat sont sécuritaires et dès
qu'elles sont dangereuses
ils ont une image mentale de leur
environnement
[Musique]
par exemple des animaux qui vivent aux
abords des routes savent qu'ils doivent
les éviter mais avec le confinement les
routes sont moins achalandées et les
animaux considère désormais c'est dieu
comme sécuritaires
pour d'autres espèces au contraire
l'effet de notre pause a été dévastateur
certains animaux en ville dépendent
beaucoup de la nourriture laissés par
les humains avec le confinement
ils se sont retrouvés femmes et des
projets de recherche s'intéresse à
quantifier l'effet de l'entreprise sur
les animaux le projet international
kovy 19 by all raguine aînés chétive
étudiera 279 populations animales dans
différents habitats de la planète à
l'aide de dispositifs électroniques
miniature mais un jour la pandémie sera
fini l'activité humaine reprendra comme
avant
quelle leçon pourras t'en tirer de cette
entrepose selon les chercheurs cela nous
aura permis d'identifier les animaux qui
sont particulièrement vulnérables à
l'activité humaine est d'améliorer la
cohabitation entre notre espèce et les
autres